people don't want to be treated like a
transaction they're looking for a
relationship and so building that
relationship is an ongoing process to
one identify with the people in the
audience to to relate to them and three
to begin to create an experience where
they buy into you as opposed to what it
is that you're offering because people
are buying into you first and so when
you develop a relationship with them and
create value for them you have an
ongoing relationship as opposed to a
one-night stand I'm here to be able to
help you educate Inspire and drawing
your audience to be able to build
conversations that create relationships
and open up opportunities and you know
that's what we're going to be talking
about today how to leverage a platform
like LinkedIn and sales Navigator
specifically on how to be able to do
that Joshua's approach is to share with
you on LinkedIn to develop a mindset I'm
not here to sell you I'm here to serve
you and when you have that kind of
approach the possibilities of what can
come out of that that I has not seen Ear
Has Not Heard nor has entered our heart
of mankind what God has in store for you
what you're about to watch is a sample
from my movement makers training it's
where I train thought leaders to build
their movement make an income have an
impact around the world I train in the
group twice a month and start to bring
in my friends as well to share their
expertise and wisdom if you want to join
us movement makers is the link in
description below and for now enjoy this
clip a Les Brown uh and I had some
breakfast this morning and we connected
last night and he said hey I'd love to
come and share some messages with your
audience you're doing some training so I
said heck yeah I'd love to have you as a
special guest so
these people here is called movement
makers they're all thought leaders
authors speakers Consultants trying to
get their message out to the world we're
going to be talking about LinkedIn and
how to how to reach out to people and
book people on our shows but in terms of
getting your message out
and connecting with people what kind of
guidance would you have for people well
first of all I want to thank you very
much for this opportunity and I'm here
to learn from Joshua I want to just make
that clear people say you can't teach an
old dog new tricks well I'm not an old
dog but I can bark
okay and I believe that you're never too
young to teach and you're never too old
to learn and and this business here
something that I was just talking
briefly with Joshua and that's major a
lot of people are intimidated by
artificial intelligence
but Joshua believes in order for
LinkedIn to work for you there are two
h's is very important it's hard work and
hard work the h-a-r-d and h-e-a-r-t
and what gives us an advantage over
artificial intelligence Marvin Gaye and
Tammy Terrell they had a song years ago
most of you don't know but I'm 78 so I
got a good memory and they had a song
called ain't nothing like the real thing
baby come on now oh behave
and so what's different than what you
have
and what Joshua brings is teaching you
how to communicate how to connect and
build a community of greatness by
speaking to people's hearts and creating
an experience and taking them to a place
in themselves that they can't go by
themselves and when you do that
expanding your your vision and your
approach beyond what is commonly seen
out there for people that are presenting
on LinkedIn uh seeing the audience as
transactions people can smell permission
breath they can smell it when they are
being treated just like someone that
they want taken from them they nobody
wants anything taken from them and so
Joshua's
approach is to share with you on
LinkedIn
to develop a mindset I'm not here to
sell you
I'm here to serve you
and when you have that kind of approach
the possibilities of what can come out
of that eye has not seen Ear Has Not
Heard nor is in it or heart of mankind
what God has in store for you so having
said that I'm getting my opinion might
be proud and I'm now going to take notes
from Reverend Dr Joshua thank you
what an intro
I appreciate that Les I just want to say
thank you so much my friend that was
amazing I'm honored to be able to be
here and I mean for to be able to share
the the desk with these two gentlemen um
and that's what we're talking about
right like how do we actually share
being able to go through I mean if you
guys don't know much about my background
but I mean like I'm gonna tell y'all
like I've been in the business for over
20 years one of my first clients was the
company that most people forgot about
these days
um and depending on your age you
probably never use the platform Myspace
so I've been doing this for a bit right
my my wife always tells me it really
shows my age when I talk about myspace
being able to go in but I actually
helped them develop one of the first
social media ads to be able to monetize
their traffic
um and it was a weird world right like I
went through and I've monetized a lot of
traffic and this is the biggest shift
right Les was talking about it today I'm
not gonna sit up here and be able to
come in and show you how to monetize
LinkedIn I'm not going to sit up here
and talk to you guys about hey let me
show you how to be able to get a whole
bunch of leads because when people come
to me and say hey Josh can you help me
get leads I'm not your guy right I'm
here to be able to help you educate
Inspire and drawing your audience to be
able to build conversations that create
relationships and open up opportunities
and you know that's what we're going to
be talking about today how to leverage a
platform like LinkedIn and sales
Navigator specifically on how to be able
to do that see you guys then everyone
excited all right just for y'all we are
all in the same room yes
it does you know we're trying to make it
work here as we're here but yeah this is
the whole thing right so I want to give
a little context right why LinkedIn and
we're going to go into I'm going to show
you specifically how to be able to use
sales Navigator but there's a couple of
pieces I want y'all to pay attention to
about why LinkedIn right LinkedIn four
to five people on that platform or
business decision makers right the
average person on LinkedIn has a college
degree or higher so you've got an
educated audience and average income
well when we look at all the different
platforms you own we look at Twitter I
think it's around 58 000 a year
Facebook's around 64 000 a year anyone
have any guesses what average income for
the United States on LinkedIn is the gas
150 97 120 Orlando you hit it right on
the bat I mean 120 000 a year so it's
almost double what the other platform's
doing so now we have a a trifecta here
right you know we have a way to be able
to actually connect with the audience
that can actually afford our products
and services that are educated enough to
make the decision and can make the
decision so that's why you want to be on
this platform the other reason why you
want to be on this platform is really
creating content it's one of the highest
most indexable sites out there for the
one platform we all want to be found on
Google right so I mean Google's out
there they're everywhere the Moz score
is 100 out of 100 on LinkedIn so
everything you do from your profile to
your content now even your comments are
actually getting indexed highly on
LinkedIn and on Google as well so it's
like a fast quick easy win for SEO for
you to be found everywhere and the big
shift that's changing and I'm actually
gonna be talking about that here at
genius Network this uh weekend is
Microsoft actually owns LinkedIn if
everyone didn't understand that it's a
26.4 billion dollars cash they pay for
the platform and they've had one of
their biggest wins like I think the
platform now is worth almost 90 billion
so talk about a huge win for Microsoft
being in there but the big thing is
their partnership with open AI right
open AI owns chat gbt and so this is
what we're looking at right the same way
that a lot of us saw Elon Musk using
Twitter or X whatever we want to call it
it wasn't to be able to own another
social media platform it was to be able
to index the human algorithm
understanding how those people worked on
that platform that's exactly what
Microsoft and open AI are doing with
LinkedIn but better so you want to be on
this platform not to be found on
LinkedIn only but to be found on Google
and now to be have you as an authority
right I want you all to be not
influencers I want you all to be thought
Leaders with influence there's a huge
difference and that's what LinkedIn can
be able to do for everyone here so with
that being said
I know I didn't have to convince y'all
to be on LinkedIn but I like to be able
to get these backs I don't think people
actually pay attention to how much
powerful is how much power is on this
platform
all right let me jump in here
and we'll go in so when we're talking
about sales Navigator it's up here on
the corner right y'all so if you have
sales Navigator it's about a hundred
dollars a month and I'll explain it this
way it's really easy to be able to
figure out if sales Navigator and
Linkedin what's going on
I don't want y'all to be on LinkedIn to
be able to sell widgets right I'm not
here to be able to teach you how to be
able to sell thousands of five dollar
products and services I want you to be
able to the people that I work with how
would we do what we do we work with
people that have high-end product
services that are adding value to this
world and really being able to create
value for them and so LinkedIn sales
Navigator is their built-in CRM system
and it's about a hundred dollars a month
if you can't create an opportunity that
results in a hundred dollars or more
for you on linked it in one conversation
then that's a I would consider what
you're doing on LinkedIn and rethink on
how you want to be able to leverage this
platform right I don't want y'all to be
able to go on here and use it like
everyone else unless I'm sure you've
gotten these messages Evan I know you
have it's like hey Les I see you wear
shirts me too let's connect yeah right
or we get the hey have you ever thought
about you know I can help you with
whatever you do because I actually
didn't take time out to be able to do
that right to be able to look we do
because what they're doing last is
they're going through here to be able to
spam a thousand people
hoping to get the one sale
and what they're actually doing is just
pissing off 999 people
and there's a better way to be able to
do it I believe
Advocates or more powerful than clients
because a client is a one-to-one
relationship y'all and that's exhausting
being able to go through but if I can
get an advocate and Advocate can bring
me thousands of opportunities so we want
to be able to go in here and teach how
do we actually connect with people so we
don't do that because that's the biggest
thing that I see with LinkedIn so let me
go into my screen here
trying to we've got so much room so I'm
trying to make sure I can see everything
so sales Navigator we're going to start
from the easy parts and having I know
your group is pretty high level but I
want to make sure we touch on some of
the basic things first yeah to be able
to go through so being able to go
through here get your home accounts
leads messaging lead filters accounts so
I love this aspect because I can
actually be able to go through and it
has abilities to be able to Define your
ideal audience better than any other
platform out there right now because we
got platforms like Facebook that have
really taken away some of the filters
that we can to be able to identify our
audience and who we really want to speak
to I don't want you to speak to millions
and millions of people that are going
through that are not going to be an
opportunity for you we want to attract
our tribe and we want to push away the
people that are not aligned with us
right we want to be really tactical with
our time because that's the one resource
we don't get back and that's why I love
sales Navigator so from anywhere like
we've got different alerts that are
coming through here priority accounts
the personas but we only have a little
bit of time and I really want to get to
everyone's question so the biggest thing
I want everyone to pay attention to is
how do we actually identify that
audience
so for us
we'll start in here with lead filters
right so these are this is the page to
be able to go through we have leads and
accounts so leads as people
accounts or companies right really being
able to go through here and be able to
look at this so I have many different
options to be able to go through from
head count to company to past company to
geography all the different ways to be
able to actually identify people how
long they've been in a company their
language what groups they're a part of
now
I want y'all to really step back
have you taken the time to truly get to
know who your audience is and what
you're trying to accomplish I know Evan
you told me a lot of people are trying
to be able to guests on their shows
right being able to go through who are
those guests what do they do how where
do they live right what are their
backgrounds what are their Hobbies right
we really have to understand someone to
give me to connect with them because if
we do we don't understand our audience
I don't care how well you're doing it
you're just pitching no one wants to
give pitched let's talk about this
already we're sick of it it's exhausting
right we want to start conversations
that build relationships because
relationships open up opportunities and
that's the biggest thing we want to be
able to do here so I'm going to show you
all this
now everything that I do on LinkedIn
honestly all it's just the things that
my mother taught me how to be able to
treat other human beings I'm just doing
it online right I'm not talking about
rocket science and so when we look at
these different things I hate cold
calling cold email I mean you guys can
raise your hand if you want if you love
cold calling Colima but like when my
phone rings and I get that two seconds
of Silence before someone says hello I'm
hitting in Bud really quickly right I
mean I'm like okay and I gotta move
forward so I want to be able to look for
trigger points there are trigger points
on LinkedIn that people are taking
action and we want to be able to react
to people's reaction right engage with
people that engage with you
so the first two points of it is someone
looks at your profile or someone engages
on your content right and we're not
going to really go into that today y'all
but like these are massive math
opportunities of the stone unturned
right to be able to connect with someone
and the human algorithm that I see
online currently all is to like comment
posts share like comment post share like
comment per share we've been
conditioning for 20 years I've been
watching it being in this space to be
conditioned to be able to do that and as
marketers we know we've got to create a
stock Gap in someone's pattern to be
able to get their attention
on that side of it engage with people
that engage with you we can look at who
looked at our posts and who engage in
our posts and who looked at our profiles
LinkedIn the only platform out there to
be able to do this and reach out and the
best stop Gap that I ever found
especially I learned this during coven
was to appreciate the things that we
take for granted
so many things in life we take for
granted now a line
a lot of times we take liking comedy
look at someone's post for granted what
if you took a second out and said hey
Evan I noticed you looked at my Pro
wow and I just want to reach out and say
thank you you know too often we don't
appreciate this let me connect to you
and find out what pushed you to look me
up or less I saw you like my recent post
I just want to reach out and say thank
you you know too I'm going to appreciate
it lovely beginning to find out what
push you engage in my content right it's
starting a conversation we're saying
thank you when someone gets thanked for
something they've taken for granted it
makes them pause and now they can hear
you so that's that side
now how do we draw in our I real
audience this is what sales Navigator is
for right and so I can go through here
Evan and I can show everyone how to be
able to go through and say okay you know
what I want to make sure I'm looking at
my only second degree connections
I want to make sure that I'm detailing
with you know what North America
and let's see here I want to talk to
let's say CEOs right being able to go
through I'm actually this one the eels
Chief physics of Optics right and so as
you're going to notice everyone in this
right hand corner this number is getting
smaller
i s still can't reach out to 150 000
people even if I wanted to do that if I
did I'm probably using Automation and if
you get caught using automation on
LinkedIn we're going to ban your account
I'm gonna tell you this right now
there's a reason why if you've ever used
one of these automated tools that are
going out there they update every day
it's not to be able to be the newest and
coolest new things it's to be able to
stay ahead of the LinkedIn algorithm so
you don't get caught
so that's the reason why they're
updating every single day if not faster
because people lose their accounts all
the time so what we want to be able to
do is I talked about trigger points
right so on the other side of it how do
I want to get someone's attention well
if I'm going in here I look at Spotlight
activities
the average person on LinkedIn I don't
care if you're a speaker you're you know
Evan Carmichael Les Brown being able to
go through their average person gets
less than one percent engagement on
their content on LinkedIn right so how
do I want to be able to get someone's
attention right I appreciate that them
for something they've taken for granted
so if I want to get Evan's CR you know
information I want to get his attention
being able to do her lesses right I'm
gonna like his post I'm going to
communize post and I'm gonna reach out
and say hey Los I saw your recent post
man I just want to say thank you you
know too often we we don't appreciate
that because I love what you said here
here and here right be able to start I'm
not
asking for anything I'm making it about
him and just saying thank you even if
Les is not running his own content
his team that took that time to be able
to build that content will appreciate
that and it opens up like okay wow this
person's different so how do we actually
identify those people
so for me we got change I'll mentioned
moves posted on links in the last 30
days
if y'all see now
on
the right hand side I can see every
single person that posts online in the
last 30 days within my searches and I
can keep on going Tighter and Tighter
right I want to make sure that you know
what years of experience I want to make
sure I've got one to two years right 146
results now I've got CEOs that have been
a CEO in the last and become a CEO in
the last one or two years in North
America that I only have a second degree
connection with right that I only got
one degree of separation
that I post online
can everyone here be able to take time
out and actually build over a month
because we only have 400 connection
requests we can use on LinkedIn every
single month because of all the spamming
in the past to be able to build these
relationships
you'll see how this is targeted how you
can actually go through so I can go in
to let's say he curls right I can see
here and be like okay I'm gonna go to
curls I can go through and I can look at
is past post right right here three days
ago he's got 11 likes no comments
so if Carl's someone I want to be able
to get in touch with and be able to go
through I'm going to read his content
I'm going to like his post and guess
what no one's commented on his post if I
comment on it I'm going to get his
attention and then when I send him a
message
now I have the opportunity to be able to
build that conversation and create that
relationship right and be able to go
through now this is how we go through to
be able to use these things same thing
if I go through for our clients and I
want to get someone
Evan is everyone they they run YouTube
shows mostly podcasts same thing yeah
YouTube Instagram I mean some are making
LinkedIn content but it's more getting
their message up in the world so YouTube
Focus okay so if I was doing that right
if I was going to go through let me let
me show you one of my saved let me see
if I can pull hold up I got one of my
old save search
English podcast right so these are saved
search and we'll go through this if I
want to this is what we do to be able to
get our clients on podcast I do this all
the time and I actually have to turn
this off
because I it overloads us to a point
that comes through that I have too many
opportunities coming through and we I
just can't do a 10 podcasts a day right
and so just like everyone else people
are going through to be able to post
stuff and on there on their podcast well
most podcasters don't understand how to
be able to leverage LinkedIn so if I'm
liking comedy and reaching out to start
a conversation
I'm able to be able to go in and say
okay geography industry professional
coaching advertising Services because
it's a specific podcast that I want to
be on English podcast host podcaster and
now I can actually find the people that
are actually Spotlight activities and
then I go in here and go Post in the
last 30 days
so I've got a list that I can actually
go through here y'all to be able to
start building these opportunities and
start building these relationships and
it works in the same way right let me
throw a bonus little pack on top of that
I'd use that when traveling and if I
have an extra day or an extra morning or
afternoon in a city I'll just go and
search for podcasters in that City that
relate to business or entrepreneurship
somehow and reach out and say hey I'm in
I'm in the city I've got uh this morning
free do you want to do uh episode for
your podcast together
and the urgency that I'm only there for
that amount of time I can create some
some leverage and some interesting
opportunities so uh it's great how how
Josh has mentioned it I've been able to
to reach out to people to do you know
Zoom or Riverside podcast but if you're
traveling or even just looking at who's
in your own City it's an opportunity as
well to get on some shows not really the
kind of what we were pitching but like
it's a great actual little bonus I think
as well to get more exposure he's unless
his profile what's he gonna do is he
going to tear it is he going to tear it
apart but not gonna share less with
profile part unless they're actually
doing anything about LinkedIn many
people do I have on my LinkedIn
well with what you know and what you're
sharing
I'm a student that's why yeah
okay and this is the whole thing Les I
mean this is what we're talking about
right like how do you if y'all want to
be able to have less on your show like
how are you going to do that like less
with 235 000 people I guarantee you he's
getting messages all the time but how do
you actually stand out right how do you
get his attention it's actually really
being able to take time out to be able
to go through like you go look at this
he's getting hundreds of engagements on
your post being able to go through but
how many people were actually going
through to say you know really be able
to go through we did this with Dan
Sullivan
um of strategic coach Dan was uh you
know known him for years while one of my
clients and you know being able to go
through here and appreciate people and
be able to get someone it was amazing
what we saw last like I talked earlier
you know about appreciating people were
taking actions
I have to take a pause here y'all just
because it always ran like one time we
reached out
and we just said Thank you to someone
right for engaging us posts because we
forget this at a time right because
we're trying to be able to create these
advocates
and we forget to always appreciate these
people that have made given us this
platform right that we are we are in
right now that we work that we we touch
every day and we just said Thank you and
his message back was amazing to Dan it
was Dan thank you
you'll never know what this means to me
today I plan on being my last
by you showing me to appreciate the
things I took for granted I will push on
thank you
and that's what's powerful y'all
right as stewards of what we do as
influencers as thought Leaders with
influence we have the ability to be able
to change people's lives with a simple
thank you
and that's what this platform on
LinkedIn can do and what I'm talking
about today how to be able to do these
things these this is what you can show
this is how you can not only build these
Advocates get people in your client but
it starts with appreciation being able
to go through now I'm going to tell
everyone here
let's say we connected with Evan right
I connected with them he took my I said
I said hey Evan thank you so much for
your recent post on X-Men really
appreciate it what does everyone usually
do next
yeah yeah then pitch something
yeah don't do that don't be like
everyone else everyone pitches
immediately right Evan's probably seen
it a thousand lessons probably seen it a
thousand times like that's not me
one-on-one that's that customer that's
not really making any of them that's not
human right like my mother taught me
when I meet someone new
to give them a compliment right oh my
God less I love your necklace you know
cool shoes Evan right love your dog
whatever it might be so this is your
opportunity to continue and this is why
I was nicknamed the dopamine dealer of
LinkedIn these are all little hits of
dopamine and not to rise someone up but
to put them in an ease so we can have
flow and have conversation right so I've
appreciated them we connected once we
connected I didn't pitch I gave them a
copy a compound on LinkedIn is endorsing
their skills
now everyone here is going to be like
well how can I endorse someone for
marketing or branding or podcasting or
whatever it is I don't know that the
first row in my house with my kids
is it's nice to be nice
right do unto others you can change
someone's life for doing that by doing
that LinkedIn goes in and says hey Evan
Josh and Dorsey for marketing do you
want to say thank you most people in
this world linkedin's doing the job for
us now
they hit that button thank you Evan so
much
now the conversation shifted right Evans
actually started the conversation with
me says hey Josh thank you so much for
endorsing me for marketing
well this is my opportunity
to ask more about them out of it man I'm
happy to do it for you hey quick
question before I have you the one
question we did for Joe and for Dan was
do you consider yourself an entrepreneur
or a business owner with an
entrepreneurial mindset right asking a
mindset question again we're making it
about them because if I ask a question
what they're doing
then once they give me a response I can
provide value not sell not Pitch not go
in through so again that question that
we did for them was do you can see
yourself an entrepreneur or a business
owner with an entrepreneurial mindset
it lets me know where that entrepreneur
either earlier on their career or
they've been doing it for too long and
they're burning the candle at both ends
right business owner with an
entrepreneurial mindset now we're
talking about someone that sees a
different their perspective they
probably have a team they've been doing
this for a little longer or we've got
the silent answer C
which is I work for somebody else
and so even if you get that silent
answer C that you're not looking for
the biggest thing I want you to
understand is you always want to not
just lead with value but leave with
value is what is what do most people do
when they get the wrong answer they're
pitching and they're asking the question
and they say oh well I I work for
someone so yeah
yeah yeah silence you never hear from
them right less yeah right that's bad
right don't do that that's amazing right
so you know being able to give value no
matter what because what we're trying to
do is create Advocates even if it's not
ready for you now they might be ready
for you later or they might go to
referringo man I would last the other
day on LinkedIn he was so amazing like
with I I asked me a question I told him
and he gave without ever asking for
anything in return
this is the opportunity also like that's
what I want y'all to be able to use
sales navigator for and I know I've
stepped off a little bit from doing
sales now respectively but we'll go
through like training based on y'all's
questions but this is how I want you to
be able to use it identify your Audience
by being able to go through and then be
able to start these conversations which
I call my engagement engine
to be able to build these relationships
and this is what you want to be able to
do and how do we actually identify right
how do we actually know the people we
want to be able to get in touch with
well I don't want to search LinkedIn all
the time to be able to go who's posting
so anyone that's going through like I
can go through and find less I can
actually save him as a lead now
right so I can save glass as you know
what he's one of my influencers now
every time last post I'm not going to
potentially miss it in the almost
billion people that are actually on
LinkedIn now I can just go to sales
Navigator
and everyone that I have saved in my
different accounts my different account
list lead lead list I'm going to be able
to see their content now I can continue
to be able to give because what we want
to be able to do what linkedin's looking
for
is for you to engage with people engage
with you to a give engagement all this
raises your visibility on their platform
their human platform right everyone goes
oh it's a B2B play now there is no B2B
or B to C right y'all that's just ways
to diversify ad spend like I've done
almost a billion dollars in advertising
and I can tell you that it's just a
different way to reverse aspect
everything is h2h human to human because
every company is around another human
being most marketers forget this and
this is how this is going to go through
so you want to be able to get people's
attention you want to get more
visibility I leveraged sales Navigator
as well to be able to find the right
people and then be able to add value to
their content on a regular basis right
to bring my visibility up and not just
go hey Evan great post that adds no
value right really to be able to go
through less has been taking notes
I want to know what what did what what
kind of notes did you take and what Josh
said what's in there well what is so
important what Josh is emphasizing again
and again and again is that people don't
want to be treated like a transaction
they're looking for a relationship and
so building that relationship is an
ongoing process to one identify with the
people in the audience to to relate to
them and three two began to create an
experience where they buy into you as
opposed to what it is that you're
offering because people are buying into
you first and so when you develop a
relationship with them and create value
for them you have an ongoing
relationship as opposed to a one-night
stand it's great so when Josh started
talking unless it's like elbowing me
it's like I need a pen I need a man
that's right I gotta write this stuff
down drop in some gyms up it here up in
here yes all right so let's get some
questions Ida what's your question for
Josh so I started watching the video
that you did with Evan on his channel
this morning and um I've kind of
implemented the strategies you talked
about them know that I was the person
that I I really love and I he posted the
content on his LinkedIn and I went ahead
and I commented on it and then he
responded to me in the DM I think he
sent me the link to his book because I
was interested in the story and I
commented on that a few months ago so it
sent me in my DM
um information is like oh if you wanted
to know more about my story you can go
check out this book and so I bought the
book I read it and then I came back I
said hey I've read your book and I have
questions and these are the questions I
have about it from from reading a book
and he responded to all the questions
that I asked but that was like months
ago and I was like okay thank you and
everything right now I want to bring him
on my show and I don't know how to go
back and reignite that conversation
because I want him on my podcast he's
Canadian I'm in Canada and I do a
podcast concerning it's a new podcast
I'm starting it's about Visionary voices
for Canadian entrepreneurs and so
entrepreneurs who are Visionaries in
their space I want to bring them on and
he's one of the people so how do I get
him on my podcast
well I mean first and foremost right
like to be able to go through Linkedin
will do the job for you if you go
through an endorsement right endure some
of his skills on his page and he'll let
them know right and sometimes they'll go
through and say thank you now if that
doesn't reignite it we want to be able
to go through what has he done recently
right what can you appreciate the action
they take because again this is the
thing that goes through as you posted on
LinkedIn recently and has he doesn't has
he doesn't has he been on a recent show
these type of opportunities you want to
have these conversations right the other
way that we've done it as well too like
when if I'm trying to get on a show
hey I love your your podcast I I just
want to you know I never know maybe let
me know who you know you actually love
to be around your show and then maybe
I can be able to introduce you some
people that would be amazing to show
hell you never know it might be right so
that's one way I do it so another way to
be able to go through
is to be able to switch that
I have so many people in my shows I know
you're doing that what kind of podcasts
do you like to be on
right asking them because
we want them to feel seen everyone wants
to be seen and heard right and so if you
ask him hey I love your presence love is
going on of course I have a podcast but
I'd love to know what kind of podcast do
you like to be on where's your ideal
audience at these days and maybe I can
introduce you some people that I know to
be able to have in your show you never
know maybe you'd be amazing fit on my
show as well right so you see how we're
actually kind of going through there and
having these conversations and really
being able to give first
I think that's the one thing that we
have to understand to be able to go
through and have these conversations
does that help a little bit
it's not very clear so the question that
you had for Dan was do you consider
yourself an entrepreneur or a business
owner with an entrepreneurial mindset so
you're kind of tweaking that to give me
a question and I can ask which would be
like what kind of podcast do you like to
go on well we're doing this because
again it's a different scenario right
like you're trying to be the one on your
broadcast so being able to go through
there it's a one-on-one like those are
that's more like the client base kind of
being able to go through to be able to
give someone opportunity when you're
trying to bring someone on your show
it's a it's a one-to-one conversation so
being able to go through there one
remembering hey you know I want to reach
out you know loved having your book we
hadn't talked in a while it's really
just having a conversation I think maybe
you might be overthinking it right being
able to go through really reach out and
just acknowledge them and sometimes it's
just like it's amazing when you have the
right person you've already had a
conversation
I mean you can just ask you know I'd
love to be able to feature in my show
and you know let me know like going
through like you're not pitching someone
and this is the difference between
asking someone to be on your Show versus
going in but I want you to be able to
have that information no you read his
book you've engaged on his posts you've
looked at his content on LinkedIn so
you've done all the things to be able to
give first and be able to show him that
you're an active participant and that
person's life if you're trying to reach
out to someone that you you're like oh
well I want to get a hold of Ariana
Huffington right like being able to go
through there just reaching out randomly
they get those all the time
right so you've had this conversation
don't overthink it truly ask I I love
you and you know I appreciate what you
shared then my audience is
this is why I know that you would add
value to them and I'd be honored to be
able to have you on my show
okay perfect because that's what I did
and he hasn't responded so I'm like okay
did I do something wrong do I just wait
no thank you I appreciate that sometimes
this endures go on the skills endorse
some skills being able to go through
there if you have that relationship
already built on there and I mean it's
just don't give up I mean like the
biggest thing is you don't Overkill
being able to go through and sometimes
people aren't always on LinkedIn no
matter if there's almost a billion
people in the platform
the average person still only spends
about 17 minutes a week on the platform
they're not losing themselves in someone
else's life like a tick tock or
Instagram right where you're like I've
lost you know I'm not trying to be able
to do that right they're going there
people go to LinkedIn to either make a
decision or get educated to make a
decision
so that's what we have to understand and
make sure that you're putting out
content as well that actually shows that
you are the authority and your space and
they will actually look at your profile
you know I talked on Evans right you
know tell me why I suck right going
through there we spent an hour and a
half going through this profile make
sure and Ida reach out to me on LinkedIn
like I said I'll look at your profile
I'm happy to be able to do that for you
all right awesome thank you I'm gonna do
that appreciate it let's bring up Mark
hey good morning guys what an honor and
privilege to be in a room with you three
uh Evan thanks for doing this is
incredible thank you I uh let my career
eight years ago as CEO of my own company
as an insurance broker and I used
LinkedIn from from the day it came about
I was on Myspace as a matter of fact I'm
I'm a little bit older than most people
and I use sales Navigator during my
entire career to build my insurance
business in exactly the same way you
just explained here so when I let uh six
years ago
I'm still on LinkedIn and I changed my
profile a little bit but I'm not using
it at all I hadn't figured out at all
how to use it with my new career which
is a YouTube channel called retirement
transformed we help people make the
transition from their corporate life
into retirement we do everything
non-financial so everyone who's on
LinkedIn is thinking about retirement
and at some point in time
what what you did today really was
invigorate me and inspire me to go back
in to really even specifically if I get
sales Navigator again just to get on
people's shows and to bring people on my
show the actual people that I want I
think it's it's incredibly fantastic and
I really just want to say thank you I
don't really have a question just
just gratitude for me being here this
morning with you three so thank you Mark
I appreciate that I mean that's what I
wanted to understand right it doesn't
always have to be about you know being
able to draw in like we want to be able
to educate Inspire and join our audience
like last said it as well one chooses to
work with you is so much more powerful
than being sold in a work with you no
matter if it's a podcast or something
like that and so this is the one thing
that we have to understand no matter if
like Bloomberg just put out linkedin's
cool again right and garyvee is on there
going stop sleeping on LinkedIn like
everyone's talking about it right now
and the big thing is no matter how much
opportunity is there we can't just put
up a post and look up in the air I'm
like look I'm no Les Brown right like
I'm not gonna get the the visibility
this man's getting already so I have to
be able to draw my audience in and
that's the one way to be able to use so
Mark you changed careers that's what
sales Navigators there for right it's
not the people biblical clients go out
there identify your ideal audience yeah
yeah right comment on their post light
them reach out to appreciate them
endorse them now you're drawing your
audience in and they're going to get
hooked on that dope meaning they want to
be able to get that again they're going
to continue to come back in because what
I want everyone here to be able to do is
I want your LinkedIn
to be a destination website that people
go every single day to be able to find
out the best information and you can't
just expect your own spine you've got to
be able to give and draw them to you
so so that's great I guess I do have a
question then we have a Business website
I have an individual website uh all my
posting I guess I do individually and
that's where I want people to go I will
find me as a resource versus The
Business website right the business
LinkedIn
human beings connect with other human
beings we don't buy I mean like Brands
right if we go through and talk about it
right if I said Mercedes Porsche or
Tesla what name comes to mind okay
right unless you're a car person you
probably don't know you only know one
name Elon Musk right right that's the
human aspect right even the season
course have been around for decades
longer most people couldn't go through
and tell you who runs those companies
right and so that's what you want to be
able to use your personal profile now I
want you to be able to take the best
that the best they get the best social
engagement and then use your business
pro page as your container not just for
other people at your business in your
company
because human beings connect with
different human beings differently right
everyone's at your social selling Army
everyone at your company okay so all the
best posts and then bring those in and
share them to your company page to be
able to highlight all the human beings
at your company that will relate to all
the different audiences okay uh the last
piece video I meant to ask this where
does video fit in on LinkedIn because
it's a lot easier for me to do video
than it is to type stuff so video is
starting to get back it takes a little
longer on LinkedIn this for video to get
kicking but I mean like definitely don't
stop remember okay first person you know
he needs you're spending 17 minutes on
LinkedIn a week so like think about that
right so your videos need to be between
30 to 60 seconds Max being able to go
through there right and we want to be
able to go through because you want to
be able to grab someone's attention and
to be able to evoke an emotion right if
you can't invoke an emotion
why are you even doing it right as human
beings we all make decisions based on
some degree of Love or hate right we
don't make decisions being indifferent
to something and so that's the one thing
I want everyone to do is you're doing
video you're doing concept meaning
you're really there you have to be
polarizing to a point and take a stand
because people are going to love or hate
you no matter what you think right to
some degree and so with their videos be
able to go through there if you can be
able to provide information value and
have open emotion within 30 to 60
seconds you've done your job and that's
what Lincoln's looking for they're not
looking for viral content y'all they
don't care about the cat videos right
like I hang in there
right the CEO recently came out and said
look I don't want better reviews I see
something going viral there's something
wrong right and so they want you to be
able to go in there and educate your
audience and that's what it's all about
so think about that thank you that was
great thank you so much okay Mary let's
hear what you've got for Josh okay good
morning everybody and Evan left and Josh
thank you so much for putting this
amazing training session together for us
um so Josh what you said in the video
that you did the tell me why I suck
video with Evan really resonated because
as uh as a mindset coach myself and
building my biz death show and getting
people to come on to like mindset
Mastery with mindset Mary the strategy
that you expressed is exactly what I did
with Instagram of like following people
that I'm not genuinely interested in
engaging on their comment on their posts
and building a relationship getting them
to kind of know me in their community
and then pitching to them whether or not
they'd be interested in coming onto the
show
um so that's worked really well and I
like the fact that I could use that same
strategy on LinkedIn my question is as a
newer coach
um how important is it for me to really
build out my LinkedIn profile and start
creating content
um that's
consistent or the ability to like reach
out to people and engage with them and
have them speak with me and then like I
guess the question is how important is
it to have a fully established profile
on LinkedIn to be able to get those
leads where people are like okay you
know she's an established coach she's
posting regularly on LinkedIn she's got
a lot of valuable information like is
that super important or should a new
coach really focus more on building the
relationship engaging with you know
meaningfully with that person and then
having and then pitching whether or not
they'd be interested to get onto the
podcast or the show I guess what's the
balance for newer coaches
Mary let me ask you this question right
so let's say you post a piece of content
or go through and someone goes to your
profile now are they going to be able to
get to know you are they going to see a
resume
on LinkedIn
on LinkedIn yeah I guess they're gonna
they're gonna see a little bit of like
an about me page but then they're gonna
see like all the jobs I've been in so
more of like a resume
this is the biggest thing unless you're
looking for a job your LinkedIn page
should not show as a resume right it
needs to be your career during a career
story like as human beings we connect
right we have to be able to find those
commonalities this is the most important
thing y'all can do if y'all do nothing
else take the time out to flush out your
LinkedIn profile more than anything
because if you're putting out content
you're sending messages out and then
they go to your profile and it's like
want like you just wasted your time and
that's the one resource we don't get
back right so why are you going to put
out content and put out put on messaging
to be able to build these relationships
if they go back out to look at you and
they they see nothing so Mary take that
time out to be able to go through like
if you look at my LinkedIn profile like
I'm just not like CEO of standard
Authority right like that's where people
stop I want them to be able to I want
that Gaff to be shortened right I want
them to see the journey that I've been
on like for me my first job on there is
I used to work at Chili's as a waiter
right and it's on there and people go
why you know we message like it like oh
my God Justin you worked at Chili's me
too connection commonality right now we
have a conversation now we have a
relationship now we have something to
talk about so being able to go through
there if you have extra credit
activities I you know I'm very blessed
in Austin Texas I I you know I'm a
resident Spider-Man Adele Children's
Hospital right these are the things that
I put on there that people not don't
think to be able to do in your about
section really take time out tell the
story from the first person you're
speaking to them
right don't talk about Mary does this
Mary like again you're not looking for a
job so and even if you are I'm gonna
tell you don't build it like a resume no
one wants to read that they want to be
able to understand your story and your
career Journey so take the time out to
be able to do that and I promise you I'm
doing a 10-minute talk here at genius
Network and honestly it's all about just
that first line I don't know if y'all
remember I talked to Evan
um and I mention it the XYZ statement so
I don't want a headline right headlines
are great that's about you we need a
customer facing forward who you're
trying to attract I help X to do y so
they can have
Z right I hope that this is my try this
is what I want to attract the people I
go oh that's not me they push away to do
why this is what you do but again no one
cares how the hamburger is made they
just can't tastes that's that Z right
that's the outcome of working with you
by going through it that's the emotional
trigger so that's so important that's
the first thing they're going to see on
your profile so if you do you don't have
time to do with that take the time y'all
to be able to do that for simple
learnings does that help me
absolutely thank you up next is Sherry
first of all uh Evan thank you so much
for this platform and this opportunity
and oh my God what oh my God I I listen
to you all the time I I even post about
you know just some of the gems that you
dropped so this is amazing and and Josh
I had the opportunity to um hear you on
um the recent one of the recent
um interviews you did with Evan and it
really resonated with me I actually
reached out to you by the way and thank
you you responded
um I really appreciated that everyone if
you actually send me a real message I
will connect if I get a blank if I get a
blank connection request like I'm not
playing Pokemon y'all I'm not trying to
catch them all and that's the biggest
problem with everyone on LinkedIn
they're just hitting that ad button all
the time and blank message requests so
thank you so much no thank you
um I'm definitely
um um I just just like Evan I actually
have been working now on trying to
update my LinkedIn profile so my hope is
that by next week I'll have it all
together so thank you I definitely took
a lot of notes on leave me a link in the
message okay I want to check it out okay
I will I will I'll definitely do that
um really quickly
um I had kind of like a two-part
question
um I noticed that um when I post
sometimes I get more engagement than
other times and I wasn't sure if there's
like a best time to post versus not and
um and you know just to understand the
algorithm more and or how often should I
be posting because I don't really post
um
that consistently to be honest and
consistency is key I mean I would say
clear consistent content to three C's to
be able to go through but I mean what
you want to be able to think about is is
this right like
for me we find the most visibility
between 8 and 10 a.m and now I'm going
to tell you like 8 and 10 AM that's your
time right where you are or
where your audience lives right so think
about that like on Central Central if
you want to go the easiest like Central
kind of kicks hits most of the central
time zone to be able to go the 8 and 10
a.m like you'll see my post they go
every single day and at 9 30 a.m exactly
my my followers know exactly where I
post when it's going on so it's
consistent just like a show right if
you're doing a show if you're listening
to something we always know when it's
going on so being able to do that is
really really important um and don't
miss out on Saturdays or Sundays right
like I always say you need to be at
least post
you know Tuesday Wednesday Thursday but
we're seeing some massive opportunity on
Saturdays as well right so the biggest
thing that we have with our clients is
we push them at least posts three times
a week right being able to go through
and don't like look at it as a heavy
lift right we look at some of these
other platforms
Twitter for example right or X or
whatever we're calling it these days
right well that platform you've got to
post at least three times a day minimum
right and I told y'all that average
income on that platform over there is
around like 48 000 a year so I'm telling
you that you're the post three times a
week
to be able to reach audience as an
average income of 120 000 a year
right so like
if that doesn't push everyone to be like
okay I can make the time to be able to
go in here and you're getting indexed on
Google and you're getting index on chat
gbt right open AI like these are the
things that we want to be able to go
through so
that's what I want y'all to be able to
think about right like when you're
creating that content and the biggest
thing is don't make it a heavy list
right you don't have to be able to go
through there the biggest thing you want
to do is at minimum three lines of
content
right because what we're looking to be
able to get is that there's a little
more button and while I'm trying to get
y'all past that right what's gonna push
that first line right if we're writing
an email right what's the headline to be
able to go through
what's going to grab someone to hit that
more button because that's what
linkedin's looking for is for them to
hit that more and be able to get dwell
time to be able to stay on your post and
stay on your content EB are doing videos
you want at least three lines of content
to be able to go through there and
talking about three the magic number
they made a whole song about it same
thing with hashtags right and
the one thing I will tell everyone too
is
we all have the access to be experts in
anything we want these days with chat
gbt and Ai and everything like that
I push you not to do that
right you can use it as a research you
can use it as a tool but I want you to
be able to understand
that what linkedin's looking for is that
we talked about with a profile here a
little bit ago your profile and what you
say that you know in your background
lines up with your content if it is out
of congruence
guess what linkedin's looking at that
they're going to break it they're going
to shift you down you're not going to
get the visibility on the post so
there's a lot that goes on with that so
that's where I want you to and everyone
too if you're gonna start creating
you're all creators on here right
because I no matter if you're on
LinkedIn yet you are a Creator go into
LinkedIn go into your LinkedIn profile
and turn on Creator mode
and we'll give you the five hashtags
that you'll want to associate with your
content
and it will help you get more visibility
and give you new tools to be able to
access and be able to connect with your
audience more
does that help a little bit oh that that
that's that's more than helpful thank
you so much and just really quickly
where does the LinkedIn lives come into
play like
um it's
is there a strategy with that and where
where is that in terms of is it
something you would recommend or
encourage or let's focus on consistent
content creation first
first we had consistent content creation
I want you to be able to go in we need
to be able to get your SSI score your
social selling index score over 70 right
being able to go through there because
again that shows that you're in the
algorithm you're doing the things that
linkedin's looking for right being able
to connect with your audience and then
get to Lincoln lives are great right now
you have to use a third party to be able
to go in like stream yard to be able to
go in and be able to stream on LinkedIn
um look if you're creating content
already you're doing a YouTube like why
not you can go through to be able to do
that but don't do a post as well right
unless you're a household name like less
they don't want to see too much content
for one person right like I'm not a
household name y'all so like I'm not
going to post more than one time a day
be with us so when you're doing the
lives too I don't want to see another
post that day and being able to go
through now if I was going to do a
LinkedIn live I'm almost gonna you're
gonna be it build an event page on it
like LinkedIn events are so powerful
people don't realize what's going on
there and what linkedin's doing is
they're working on because again
Microsoft owns LinkedIn y'all so we
already have teams and stuff like that
that's on the background of what they're
building in to be able to actually start
putting their own video out and hosting
that on LinkedIn I've seen I was at
linkedin's offices about two months ago
and I mean talking with them about what
they're doing with AI and where they're
going and it will come we're gonna see
like I would it was one of the first 200
people to use LinkedIn audio right
they're going through a lot of different
the audio rooms they're very similar to
clubhouse so we're seeing these things
but first and foremost
go through I'd rather you be able to go
through be able to do the content if
you're going to do a LinkedIn event a
LinkedIn live run an event and then
I've actually got I'll send it to Evan
I've got a cheat sheet to be able to how
to run LinkedIn events and I'll make
sure I send it to Evan for you all to be
able to have that and be able to
leverage it and I mean we we help our
clients every single month consistently
get anywhere from 200 to a thousand
registrants every single month and when
you do it the right way not only are you
getting those people that are registered
but you're also getting their emails to
be able to nurture them um prior to that
as well too thank you so much I
appreciate it we have Tanya next hey
Tanya Connie out well blessed to be here
with all of you guys and then thank you
for playing this together feel honored
just to be in the same room with you
guys
um I guess my question is like LinkedIn
and wow I haven't actually considered
LinkedIn for quite some time but now I'm
seeing this is something I should get my
head into it's kind of a basic question
but since my original LinkedIn I mean
I'm trying to see if I can even get
access to it so I guess that would be
the question if I can't get access to my
original LinkedIn would it be best to
revive that and like move forward
creating who I am now instead of you
know what it whatever it is or was I
don't really know I guess I was looking
at jobs one time because I know I'm
heard about it before
um or just starting from French all over
again like having I don't know if it had
like a on member since 2000 whatever
like is that valuable to have out there
or just like scrap that idea and just
move forward with the new one I don't
know get in let's get in right I mean
there's no reason to be able to start
over or you're there but if you can't
yeah just just be able to go through
because LinkedIn doesn't want to be able
to see multiple uh profiles right so
that's the bigger thing oh well I'm just
going to create 10 different profiles
I'm gonna use a strategy and I'm gonna
get past their 400 connection requests
I'm gonna go through here like so like
they're actively using that and again
with their partnership with openai
they're using AI actively to be able to
monitor all these things right to really
need to go through when be proactive
this is why a couple months ago we saw a
huge decrease in in followers from some
of the biggest accounts out there I mean
look maybe I lost some because they use
a to go through and clear out any fake
followers that were in the system being
able to go through them
so that's the one thing so go through a
bigger profile this you can actually go
through and try and say hey reset my
password
as long as you still have access to that
email and get back in and then go
through take that time and really be
able to tell your story through your
profile and I promise you it'll really
work out yeah that's what I'm looking
forward to because like I'm doing
digital like I still have a day job and
everything in healthcare and like I'm a
CNA and administrative coordinator but
like I want to be more of an
inspirational speaker and I want to
write a book I have all these things I'm
working towards but like the nerves of
like people that I already do have on
there might be like work related people
so I guess it's just time to like you
know but being shy about it all and just
keep moving forward so all right well
thank you don't be shy because again my
wife when she worked at Microsoft she
used to run branding over the Microsoft
partner Network and she started building
her personal brand after being with me
and stuff like that now she actually
works in standard Authority well I
she'll kill me if I say Works she
actually is a part she's 20 owners in
standard Authority now
um being able to go through but that's
what she started doing being able to put
herself out there and most companies
that they realize how much value you're
bringing
they're going to highlight you they
started highlighting her at Microsoft
and next thing you know she took over
they said hey do you want to run the
Microsoft partner network podcast right
because of what she was doing and
showing up right always understand what
your company is social you know
guidelines are always stay within that
but don't hide who you are and if the
right companies are out there they're
gonna see you shine and they're going to
help you shine anything greater I
thought that might be a good one for
Less to jump in on to get some
perspective Tanya is a little shy to get
her message and her story out what what
kind of guidance would you give somebody
like her who's trying to share their
story
Tanya the story you're sitting on
someone is waiting on
you were born and preserved for such a
time as this
so decide that it's worth it for you to
live full and to die empty and to do
your part in making the planet a better
place you were chosen you're a
masterpiece because you're a piece of
the master that's my story now I'm
sticking to it son
I do agree with that actually I'm
actually going to be doing a speaking
thing at my day job in a couple weeks
it's actually kind of funny because they
rescheduled it and so it actually falls
on International Talk Like a Pirate Day
and I was like oh I would love to help
present on like a very small part of the
presentation but I'm dressed as a pirate
is that okay and they were like this is
the best thing I've heard all day I'm
like I'm winning on this so yeah Captain
T is coming out to play at work we love
it all right cool uh well Mike saw back
over and uh bring up Orlando Orlando
what do you have for Josh
good morning everyone it's so nice to
see everyone here it's been a little
while uh I'm Les Brown you've been
awesome on those lives on LinkedIn I was
in LinkedIn for a little while and you
were just crushing it so I can see why
you have 234 000 followers uh Joshua
your stuff is awesome I I've been
following your principles just naturally
right just like you know if someone is
just to come across you in the street
you know and say hi I know you from
somewhere you wouldn't just ignore that
this is what we do with all those DMS
and such respond right engage
um so you can actually answer a lot of
the questions I did have originally when
I when I raised my hand in terms of
content strategy what is LinkedIn
looking for in a very high level kind of
guidance here
um but I'm gonna kind of give it a
two-part question so
why don't we dive into if you don't mind
what do you think is more effective is
it the content strategy that brings
inbound conversations of the audience
you're looking for you know to work with
or is it more the outbound effort of
using the Navigator finding the people
you really want to work with directly
and then reaching out and depending
which one you say right
I have a follow-up question on that
Orlando I love that my friend I mean
like look content's great but all it
does is what you need to be able to use
your content for is to back up what you
know to be able to show that you
understand you add value you educate
your audience right it will create
conversations but what you have to be
able to you can't expect conversations
and opportunities to come from just
posting content out there so you know we
live by the 10 20 70 method of content
creation I don't know if I talked about
that with Evan last time or not but
um and it actually aligns with what
LinkedIn recently came out with on what
they're looking for right 10 of your
content needs to be human right it needs
to be personal right human beings
connect with other human beings we look
for commonalities now it doesn't need to
be like Facebook right I don't need to
know when your kids are going to school
but I need to know you have like oh Josh
you have kids me too right like now we
have a connection now we have a bond to
be able to go through
and what I always call this Orlando is
the the door to the couch mentality
right assuming knocking on your door
like everyone does on LinkedIn trying to
pitch you windows or whatever it might
be either sell you a pin you know it
takes you and I
um to put us on the count Trey takes you
from the door of the couch hanging out
and Orlando you and I are hanging out
I'm like hey Orlando dude I got this new
phone you're like wow man tell me more
right now you're asking me about what I
have and giving more information 20 of
your content needs to be around your
company
but not about what you can do for others
no one cares that you can make them
seven figures show them how you've
helped someone else right being able to
go through there we want to be able to
use stories to be able to share so
people can see themselves in the eyes of
the people that you've helped in the
past right because oh that's me oh I
want that I want to be able to go
through they want to be able to relate
we only do this 20 of the time
because you never want to be that
personal room right in Orlando you never
want to we've all been those those
events like oh
there's Josh that dude never shuts up
about LinkedIn avoid avoid avoid like we
don't want to do that so we only want to
talk about our company our business what
we've done for others 20 of the time
then 70 add value educate your audience
anything you learned from last you learn
from Advent you learn from me like it
doesn't always have to be your
conscience as well I want you to be an
aggregator of value right not only
educating from what you learn from your
own past experiences but what you learn
from others being able to draw them in
because if they do that they're going to
go to you every single day and go wow
okay Orlando's the guy that'll be able
to follow through even if it's less as
information that you're sharing to them
they're going to go to you for the
solution if you educate them enough
that they have an issue that you can be
able to help them solve and so that's
what you want to be able to think about
the content side the Outreach is they go
hand in hand you can't do one without
the other if you put out content just
look in the sky it's like going okay
wait for my money right
you've got to be able to take action
right so that action is beginning to
draw that audience in being able to
start the conversations give to receive
so doing those messages so that's what I
want you to think about Orlando posting
three times a week but then I want you
to go through what 10 people again I'm
just turning everyone small right you
have up to 400 connection requests you
can do every single month
that's a hundred a week but what if you
said what five or ten people can I reach
out to
this week that are my ideal audience
that I can start a conversation with
like and I can I can really help I can
support I can add value to and build a
relationship with
right if if someone says they don't have
time to do that then I mean like look
it's we're talking about three posts a
week
five outreaches you know to be able to
engage on someone's post you should be
able to do that in 30 minutes or less
every single day especially using sales
Navigator does that help it does and and
and so that's the one-two punch there
um so that follow-up question is what is
the sequence that you recommend using
for the follow-up for the for the
conversation it's private you know how
many contacts you know there's whatever
model you use right because there's
different models and sales you have to
have certain number of contacts if you
just have three contacts you you know
you're gonna have a certain percentage
of conversion if you hit 12 maybe you're
right another level so what is your
recommended sequence in terms of the
initial hello where you move the
conversation to yeah
um how many how many how many you know
back and forth does it talk about a
little bit it's my engagement and so
it's you know one engage with people
that engage with you right or you know
being able to go through and appreciate
you know be able to appreciate someone
that has engaged in your post looked at
your con you know looked at your profile
or posted great content right so we
reach out hey just want to reach out and
say thank you for post profile content
right we wait for them to be able to
connect once they connect so that's our
first cut point right they connect once
they connect we endorse right we give
them a compliment right they reach out
and say hey yo Emma thank you so much
for you know endorsing me no problem we
asked a qualifying question right and we
ask about them once they respond back to
that we add value that value can be from
anything right is it is it you know
that's amazing you know I love that
perspective I love working with people
that that think this way now we eat the
qualifying questions that I find work
best
mindset questions so I go in there like
you make a million dollars a year
No One's Gonna tell you that
do you have issues with your marriage
they're probably not going to jump in
and be able to jump in and be like oh
yeah that's that man I've never met you
before like let me tell you about this
so asking someone how they think how
they feel how they go through allowing
them to be able to share people like to
be able to share their mindset and so
that allows you to be able to go in and
be able to take the next steps that's
amazing I love working with people that
think this way I love to you know
hearers love to invite you to an
exclusive Master Class I'd love to share
with you this PDF that I think will add
value or
man I love how you think like that I
mean I don't know if you have 15 minutes
I'd love to learn more right and when
you if you get on a call to talk with
them
and this is human nature right we want
to be able to go through you let them
talk wow Orlando man tell me more about
yourself man I love that you answer the
questions and they go through them now
naturally what do people as human beings
what do we do right when we have a
conversation to go through I just went
through Orlando and I tell you
everything about me
what am I going to do next
oh man Orlando let's talk for 10 minutes
about me like what are you up to
guess what that wall that we all build
to be able to put up so we don't get
sold is now down you've now been invited
in
now you can have a real conversation
about that relationship and create the
opportunity awesome thank you that's
very concise very very well put and
obviously from there it's a sales effort
um when you're doing this on a regular
basis like this is organic like around
doing paid advertising so like if you're
consistently doing this and using your
400 every single month like it just
builds up and builds up and builds up
and builds up and then this is long tail
you we have people that'll come in like
I'll have clients that are work with
like let's say six months a year and
then a year after like hey Josh are you
still on our accounts
because they're still getting messages
back that they had sent to people
because they didn't maybe they just
weren't online didn't write that and so
this is that opportunity it's not just
immediate it creates a pathway for you
to have opportunity
extending for months and months let's
get one more uh and then we'll get some
final words from less and then we'll
wrap uh we have hika up you pronounce my
name right yay the first time ever
somebody does it the first time thank
you um I'm excited to be here thanks
everybody my question really quick
um I get bombarded with exactly what you
said that piss you off those all those
messages about somebody trying to sell
me marketing service and have what have
you any elegant way to deal with that
I mean look I get all the people I'm
gonna get a message that says hey Joshua
B so on LinkedIn y'all my first name is
Joshua B so I can pick up automation
really quickly hey Joshua B ever thought
about using LinkedIn to get leads and
honestly you should get really upset and
my wife was like like you I'd be like
are you kidding me like you're
representing anyone that's trying to
help people on LinkedIn the wrong way
like this is you think that if you spam
me like I'm like oh wow you do this so
good I'm gonna hire you you can do this
for my account too like it doesn't work
right like and I would go back and
respond to that
you know it's I really say Follow Your
Heart Right like for me if someone cold
pitches me
I just removed my connection to them
right we're not connected anymore done
right if they're trying to connect with
me I don't accept it right I'm like
trying to go through so it makes it
really easy for me to be able to really
hone in my audience and the people that
I aligned with so cool Cole pitched me
all day I used to and if it's someone on
LinkedIn they're like a LinkedIn expert
and I hate to use the word expert
because I don't think any of us are
experts we're always constant Learners
you know really learning and honing our
craft every single day if you've hit a
pinnacle like you
whatever I won't get into that whole
aspect but I mean like this is that
whole piece straight like I always want
to be able to learn and so this is that
whole piece like you can share like go
through hey here's a better way there's
someone from your industry of course
saying this is the better way to be good
but like remember your time is valuable
right that's the one resource we don't
get back so like delete move on move
forward
awesome thank you yeah I've been
ignoring and but it's it's been
affecting me not being motivated to do
more because the more I've been doing
the more I show up I guess in the
algorithm for them to reach out so I
just need to learn to ignore and and
just do my thing I do my best I can to
be able to educate everyone as fast as
possible let them know that they're
doing the wrong thing it's awesome I do
my job on my side and hopefully that'll
help thank you appreciate it so we've
got a few minutes left I wonder actually
uh before final words if Josh has a
question for less you're given so much
value to the members here today you got
a chance to ask the legend you got to
speak loudly into my mic but first no
you know less
I've always I've followed you for many
years how you this represent as a human
being how do you add value to support a
lot of what I talked about today is very
representative a lot of how you treat
and share and I see people going through
as you would hear some of these things
I've gone through on LinkedIn and how I
live ReSound like what are your thoughts
I mean because again I look at that
human algorithm being the connects and
for me
I know I try to change this world my own
in my past and it's a it's another story
to be able to go through but I
I was very blessed on getting your
permission to be able to continue on and
not and
trying to change the world so like for
me I know to work with other people like
you and Evan is really what we have to
do to be able to change the world for
the better so when you look at this
process when you go through
have you seen successful LinkedIn and
how does something like what I'm talking
about today represent to you I think
it's very powerful the things that
you've been sharing and I most certainly
will Implement that something I'd like
to share with people that you have been
saying and that I feel that's important
that allowed me when I decided to come
into this industry to stand out I'd like
for people to really make a special note
of this never let what you want to say
get in the way or what your audience
needs to hear
well then okay that most people come in
and they have some information that they
want to do an information down yeah I
remember going to a doctor and obviously
there was some communication mix-up and
nurse came in and she was reaching for
us in petroleum jelly and and put in and
put on some gloves and I say what's up
and then she said you you were here for
you're right you want to have your
prostate examinations I said no I have
an ear infection
we just bleached
so that that many people they got stuck
on their chest and they just want to get
it off right
when you're communicating with people
through a podcast or on the stage it's
no place for therapy and not just
telling the story for the sake of the
story everybody's got a story and when
you just come up and don't have the
coaching and training that you provide
that allow people to tell their stories
strategically to distract dispute and
Inspire how people live their lives as a
result of the story they believe about
themselves so when you are doing your
podcast and you take the time to know
your audience that I think and I want
everybody to keep this in mind listen to
the listening
take the time to listen to how people
are listening to you because people
listen in one of three ways some hear
what they want to hear some hear what
they think they hear and some hear
what's really being said and so in all
thy getting getting understanding
understanding who you are talking to and
how can I provide a an approach with my
knowledge my experiences to distract
them from their current story and
through my presentation of this podcast
dismantle their current belief system
and Inspire them to become his Mother
Teresa would say to become a pencil in
the hand of God and start writing a new
chapter with their lives that's what you
do and on the youth is that yes sir
amazing so any final words now for
movement makers if you want to give some
guidance or again coaches thought
leaders creating content
trying to get their message out to the
world yeah one of the most important
things to do is is to be an observer
that the best speakers are the best
listeners
and observed life and something else
that's very important
when you're doing a podcast or you're
doing an interview
on anybody's program
to be able to
provide information
and do it synthesize it so that that
when people hear that will stay with
them all right ladies and gentlemen I
was at airport God told me to continue
the circle
and I know many of you have had that
experience now I'm bringing the audience
into the conversation
and but I saw this officer who was
talking to a young lady he didn't make
her Circle
and so when I came back Riley told me
keep moving I said no
when she goes I go and we got into an
argument and he said don't have me call
back up I said you call whoever you want
to call
and there was the lady who was watching
and came to me and said Les Brown listen
no one knows him I know you I know the
work that you do she said
trouble is easy to get into but hard to
get out of
keep circling
so I took a very simple situation that
many of us have experienced circling at
the airport and that statement trouble
is easy to get into but hard to get out
of and so having statements that people
can hear that I was about to get angry
and then I thought about the fact that
anger is a whim that blows out the lamp
of the mind that you don't just say it
but you experience it so that people as
a result of it they feel what you're
saying and are willing to embrace that
and allow them to create a new chapter
with their lives
amazing thank you well so if you guys
want to reach out to Josh each this way
is on your LinkedIn I think we've linked
that up if we can put that in there
we'll have to do a round two with less
this is a surprise what is it he's like
what are you doing to my last night like
what are you doing tomorrow it's like
well I'm doing I invited about that he
did not invite me and I told him I said
you know and then I heard this quote
about Marcus it really is never go where
you are not invited so I said I'm sorry
it's when I invited myself you didn't
tell me to come and so he didn't want to
hurt my feelings so he told me to come
in here I don't know that was more like
we're doing training on LinkedIn
when you can come if you want and so uh
anyway we had breakfast and he came out
so yeah so we'll do we'll go around to
proper and I think there's a lot a lot
of people here would love to learn from
your advice I saw some questions about
um do you have a training program or
teaching yes I'm I'm training people I'm
doing a one-on-one coaching with a
limited number of people what I do is
extract a person's story teach them how
to all denies it and how to create an
experience with their story all of the
window home said that once a man or
woman's mind has been expanded with an
idea concept or experience it could
never be satisfied to going back to
where it was and so I'm I've got a
training that people go to lesbrown.com
is called Master the mic and it what I'm
doing is showing people how to begin to
use their their personality the the how
to speak from their heart to the hearts
of the people that they talk to but
there's something else that we have not
touched on because of the limited time
and that is asking strategic questions I
slope for a major corporation and I saw
sign when I was about to leave and I
want you to everybody make a mental note
of this don't leave any money on the
table and then and the sign said the
danger zone
so
I happen to be seated by the CEO I said
what does that sign name the danger zone
he said well we're going to be teaching
about this how to communicate with their
patients and let them know if they don't
take their hypertension medication
they can have a heart attack or stroke
and ask him I said do you have high
blood pressure he said yes I said why do
you take your medication he said because
I want to live
may I ask you another question he said
yes why do you put together and spending
millions of dollars for a fear-based and
they why not talk about the success Zone
and appeal to people's desire to want to
live
he said can you train doctors I said
absolutely
now they had all kind of doctors phds
and mba's there
I got the contract here's what the other
doctor here's the other presenters did
they came in with the information from a
medical perspective
I am preparing for that presentation I
had interviewed several doctors so that
I could incorporate what they were doing
with their patients to develop a
relationship a connection like just a
doctor touching someone on the show so
I'm glad you came in today reduces
malpractice suits by 37 percent wow I
got the contract one month 16 speaking
engagements six hundred and forty
thousand dollars now a lot of people
work a whole month
and I mean a whole year they'll earn 640
000 so that one month because I asked
that question and I found out from the
man who writes the jack
why he would be willing to write that
check if I could come up with something
that was better than what he already had
on the table did you feel a brother up
at here up at here 640
000 a good garden and a healthy heart
and you can make it through the winter
that's my story and I'll stick it to it
well if you want to see less breakdown
my story we he had me on his show and
it's on it's on our YouTube channel too
it's got over a million views uh he
talks about well he pulls out my mom and
all this stuff yes breaks me apart uh
live on camera if you want to go watch
that we'll link it up
um Joshua B Lee on LinkedIn
lesbrown.com yeah that's the master the
mic I'll teach you how to master the
stage where when you finish your
presentation not only will you transform
lives but you will increase a demand for
you to become a high paid compelling
speaker and you'll be able to grow your
community because it's about today
building collaborative achievement
driven supported relationships in order
to make it in this new space Where We
Are
and that's a show to see Joshua break
down my LinkedIn strategy check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe see
you there I don't think people are
paying attention they keep on sleeping
on LinkedIn like linkedin's been around
for 20 years they're owned by Microsoft
they bought LinkedIn for 24.6 billion
dollars cash and now that platform's
estimated to be over 80 billion